c'est une épidémie silencieuse méconnue
de notre côté de l'Atlantique voilà
comment Brice Lambert décrit
l'incarcération des femmes dans l'État
américain de l'Oklahoma il est le
réalisateur du documentaire inédit femme
en peine les oubliés de la mairie en 40
ans on est passé là-bas de 26000 à plus
de 230 000 femmes derrière les barreaux
en criminologie on appelle ça du
stockage de détenus la faute à des lois
extrêmement sévères et complètement
misogyne d'après Suzanne sharp
spécialiste de l'incarcération féminine
nous avons des lois très sexistes en
Oklahoma et elles sont toutes autour du
rôle des femmes en tant que mère
nous sommes prétendument un pays moderne
mais nous sommes en fait un pays très
misogyne
concrètement ça veut dire que des femmes
sont condamnées à 30 ans de prison pour
avoir été arrêtés avec un sachet de
drogue quand le mari qui est le dealer
lui n'est pas inquiété par la justice ou
comme Tony passait 14 ans en prison
parce que son conjoint a frappé ses
enfants en son absence et que la justice
considère qu'en tant que mère elle
aurait dû savoir que ça pouvait arriver
le film avance plusieurs explications à
ces peines qui semblent injustes et
disproportionnées le fait que les juges
soient élus et que chacun cherche à
prouver qu'il sera plus sévère que le
candidat d'en face et puis il y a
l'influence des chrétiens évangéliques
rigoriste qui considère selon Susanne
sharp toujours que la femme est
inférieure à l'homme et qu'elle doit
rester à sa place de mer femme en peine
les oubliée de l'Amérique un film coup
de poing à découvrir ce samedi à 21h sur
Public Sénat